unfortunately that's what we've seen
with the origin of kovit it's it's
gotten to this very bizarre situation
where if it comes from a market somehow
the democrats win or if it comes from a
lab the republicans win
but the truth of the matter is like
if we don't find the origins like we all
lose together hello john perry here it
is january 1st 2022
welcome back my guest today is dr alina
chan she has agreed to come back on to
respond to some of the questions and
concerns that my viewers had last time
she was on dr chan has been very vocal
about the possibility
that covet 19 might have jumped from
animals to humans through an accident at
a medical research lab
i do recommend you listen to our first
video if you haven't seen that yet but
just a little bit of background before
she comes on at the start of the
pandemic various lab leak hypotheses
were talked about in the media as if
they were fringe conspiracy theories
believed only by extreme right-wing
christians and republicans because of
this a lot of my viewers have thought
it's odd that i have been interested in
various lab league hypotheses because i
mean
i'm an atheist and
i tend to lean pretty far to the left
politically but the truth is there are
many scientists and journalists and
educators from all different sorts of
political and religious backgrounds who
have been worried from the start that
cobia 19 may have accidentally leaked
from a medical research lab as of now
january 1 2022 most scientists and
public health officials still suspect
that kova 19 most likely had a natural
origin and personally i do lean that way
as well
but even among us on team natural most
of us do recognize that an in-depth
investigation into the possibility of a
lab leak does need to happen i do not
have any accounting of what the chinese
may have done and i'm fully
in favor of any further investigation of
what went on in china maybe they could
have been studying it and accidentally
it infected a few people and got
released that's total speculation but i
don't think we could rule that out many
letters signed by scientists have now
been published by traditional media
outlets as well as in various scientific
journals calling for a thorough
international investigation
into the possibility of a lab leak who
tried to do that the results were not
satisfying to anybody we need to try
again here with real access to all the
information and find out what really
went on this letter here was co-written
by dr elena chan but she was not alone
along with her name we find that of
ralph barrack a virologist who used to
work directly with the wuhan institute
of virology he is one of several
scientists who has helped them
genetically modify coronaviruses for
medical purposes and he believes their
lab the lab of his own colleagues does
need to be investigated also on this
letter we find the name of dr david a
relman relman is a microbiologist from
the stanford school of medicine but more
importantly for many years now he has
played an active role consulting the u.s
federal government on biosafety issues
in the field of virus research
he has a very deep and very broad
understanding of the types of research
happening all around the world he is
very familiar with the risk benefit
calculations done to justify dangerous
research and he helped shape some of the
safety protocols used by scientists that
work with risky pathogens what i'm
trying to say here is that even though
alina chan is probably the most vocal
scientist right now about the
possibility of a lab leak she is not
just another one of these lone wolf
scientists or medical professionals that
we keep seeing pop up throughout this
pandemic to sell us a new tin hat
conspiracy theory alina's concerns are
well founded and have been endorsed by
many other researchers who have a deep
understanding of the situation
surrounding the origin of covid19
each question and topic discussed today
came directly from our viewers either
via youtube comments under our last
conversation or via emails sent directly
to me sadly we did not have enough time
to cover every single question but the
the things we covered were really
interesting and i had a lot of fun with
this conversation
we start by addressing a question asked
by youtube commenter stefan
why does it the origin of kova 19
matter right now and as you'll see
stefan's concern seems to be shared by
francis collins the former director of
the national institutes of health
long-time followers of mine will know
that even though elena and i disagree
with his statement on this particular
topic i do have great respect for that
man and i was i was really sad to see
him retire alina and i saved all the
juicy click bait for the end of our
conversation
there we talk about the reported rise in
racism against people of asian descent
and we discussed the co-author of
alina's book
matt ridley he's a guy who some of my
viewers really don't seem to like
so without further ado here is my
conversation with dr
alina chan
thank you for sharing your time i don't
know how you're doing all this and your
job it's crazy i just work extra hard
and then pass out
um yeah i've tried to say no to as many
interviews as possible but i value this
one because the audience is different
yeah so yeah i like it a lot that you
are you're a scientist like you're
scientifically trained and your audience
is very science interested
um and that's why they're getting all
these really interesting comments right
i feel like it's more of a deep dive
than i usually get with the more
basic like first time interviews cool
great
you said you wanted to start by talking
about francis collins his retirement for
those who don't know francis collins is
was the director of the national
institutes of health in the usa francis
collins just retired
and
you wanted to talk about something that
he said
when he went on fox news right he said
that the lab leak was a distraction
he was trying to talk about omicron
and he kept getting interrupted to talk
about
the lab league
let's just take a look at the clip
well brad i'm really sorry that the lab
leak has become such a distraction for
so many people because frankly we still
don't know there is no evidence really
to say most of the scientific community
myself included think that is a
possibility but far more likely this was
a natural way in which a virus left a
bat maybe traveled through some other
species and got the humans and there was
no lab leak involved we won't know until
as china decides to open up about this
which they have not done and shame on
them for that
yeah i think that the enough scientists
in this world that both important
questions can be addressed at the same
time and that's actually what we saw
china doing in the early days of the
covet 19 outbreak the reason for having
to urgently identify the source of the
origin of the pandemic is so that you
can shut down these sources of the virus
right because pandemics and outbreaks
grow in exponential manner so you can be
doing your best efforts to put out the
fire as it grows exponentially but if
you don't turn off the the faucet where
the water is pouring out where this
virus is spilling over or leaking from a
lab let's say
just more and more of it will come out
and that's why both need to be addressed
at the same time uh we've seen taiwan
recently do that very efficiently so
when uh sas kovi to escape from a
biosecurity level 3 lab in taiwan not
only did they immediately contact trace
all of the hundreds of people who had
been exposed to this individual from the
lab but they also went straight to the
lab start sequencing the strains trying
to match it to the patient strain so
they they could do both things at once
it's not a situation where we have to do
all the contact tracing do all these
other things first and then years later
and come back and see how did this get
started so for those who don't know and
i think most americans didn't ever hear
about this but there was a lab in taiwan
that was studying sars kovi 2 so this is
recently this is like a couple days ago
or a couple weeks ago one of the
researchers was bit by a mouse
she started to feel a little bit sick
but she didn't imagine she had kovid
because no one in taiwan right now has
coveted right they've completely stomped
it out yes taiwan is actually a zero
covert country so they they have
extremely few cases before this uh
scientist was found to have
caught covet uh there had been a span of
some 35 days with zero new covet cases
in taiwan right
and so she got covered from her mouse
from a mouse that she was working with
so that part is still kind of unclear so
uh but the taiwanese authorities are
taking this very seriously and they
immediately went to the lab once they
knew about this diagnosis and they
started testing everything the surfaces
the mice uh and they discovered that
this this worker who was in her 20s had
been bitten not once but actually twice
by mice in the lab while working with
them they found that the mice had been
handled outside of the bios
biosafety cabinet so in a place where
you are more exposed to it even though
you're still fully decked in protective
equipment
they found that there was uh virus
contaminating door handles and tables in
the bsl tree facility uh they found that
uh it's possible that because the worker
took her mask off first before the rest
of her outfit she might have
contaminated herself that way so there's
actually multiple ways that she might
have caught it in the lab rather than
the mouse bite yeah i did think that was
a little bit weird because
i mean through the blood directly is an
unusual route i know that we have ace2
receptors in our blood vessels so you
could get covered through there but she
seemed to be
expressing normal coveted symptoms right
which would seem like she must have
gotten infection in her respiratory
tract
it's difficult to know because uh
the way that some some scientists have
done experiments uh inoculating animals
with uh with style such viruses is that
in some in some cases they even do an
inoculation into the brain so they
inject it into the brain of the animal
and yet the highest titus are still
found in lungs afterwards
yeah so it it's unclear
how many different ways it could get
into your body but it's to manifest in
the same symptoms and the surprising
thing was that this worker had been
fully vaccinated with moderna
so she she i can understand why she
wouldn't think that she had covet even
when she developed a fever and she was
going about town for more than a week
without testing because she had been
fully vaccinated uh she had been told by
a supervisor that it was fine
that this
that it was unlikely for her to get
infected with coven in the lab because
of her status and she was young as well
so but eventually when she lost her
sense of smell and taste that's when she
was like yeah i should probably go get
tested right so then she went and got
tested and by then she had been in the
community there to
test like more than 100 people and put
them put a lot of them in the quarantine
okay so
did do we know if she spread it to
anyone else
so far it doesn't seem like it so it's
quite lucky that she didn't oh man that
that really is a scary story and
the
i mean it does highlight
of course the
possibility of a lab leak right i mean
it's just one one other little
bit of circumstantial evidence again
very circumstantial evidence this is a
totally different incident
but the thing with taiwan is that it's a
zero covert country so it's it's fairly
straightforward when the scientist gets
infected with south korea that you're
like yeah maybe
it's from the lab but in places like the
u.s even though they're probably dozens
of labs working with sars kobe 2 samples
or virus
there's no way to really know whether
the scientists got infected in the lab
or in the streets like true exposure to
people
you're saying that they were able to do
contact tracing they were able to stomp
it out
it looks like they've stomped it out
yeah so the it looks like it probably
never even went to anyone yeah and if
even if it did they've quarantined
everyone that she was in contact with
and the people that they were in contact
with yeah
they're taking this very seriously
well even that if she had gotten on a
plane it would be impossible to to
to track that you know it's a really
good example of how how easy it is to
spread a virus
then that actually happened with the
first sas virus so it had been studied
at a bsl4 the highest biosecurity level
lab
in taiwan as well and this researcher
had been infected and then went on an
international trip to singapore to
attend a conference
thankfully he only developed symptoms
the day after he landed back in taiwan
so imagine if he had gotten sick or had
a longer trip in singapore it would have
been an international incident
yeah and for those who don't remember
sars kovi one really only spreads when
you are showing symptoms it doesn't have
the asymptomatic spread like like stars
kobe 2. so yeah yeah
is there anything else that you want to
say about that like the importance of
focusing on both of these things right
now yeah so i think we can do both at
the same time and in fact we need to do
both at the same time um i also
want to press the point that this
pandemic we will
never
finish we will never finish with covet
19 like there will always be covet 19
around the world ongoing somewhere
especially in underprivileged places and
developing countries so
pandemics also have a
disproportionate effect on places where
it's difficult to get health care
difficult to get access to vaccines to
diagnosis so
we we will never run out of new variants
you know what i mean like today it's the
omicron like next week who knows what it
will be like we're gonna start naming
variants after like constellations so
it's uh there will never be a day when
people are like okay we're done and now
we can go look at the origins
yeah it's very problematic and that's
why i think we really have to prevent
future pandemics future loss of life
future burdens on developing countries
by stopping these pandemics as they
happen like
on day one so knowing how they happen
and stopping those processes from from
leading to future pandemics
i know that a lot of people are mad at
francis collins and uh anthony fauci be
well for one reason they've they were
classically in favor of gain of function
research i think
like as we dig into the origin stuff i'm
sure there's gonna be a big trial in the
u.s and it's gonna it's probably gonna
be on tv and it's gonna be a big huge
deal all the things that they said in
the past about gain of function research
and virology is gonna get brought up and
people are gonna wanna hate them
but francis collins has done an
excellent job he's been on the wrong
side of some arguments but he's done an
excellent job his comment the other day
when he's saying that as he was leaving
that this is a distraction
his job is not to accuse china of crimes
against humanity
like
that's
ever since the start of this pandemic
that
the healthcare officials in the united
states have been very careful in their
comments to the public
not to say anything that would offend
people in china
and some people are saying all they're
just being weak they should just
confront this but
what they have to do behind the scenes
is they have to work with people in
china to try and get as much information
as they can so it never made sense for
them to attack you know we have we do
have politicians that you could say it
is their job to do this tom cotton
bringing to the public's attention that
this pandemic might be a result of a lab
accident and he was doing that from the
very start and he was being very harsh
with china and i think that division of
labor makes sense
because
we
you don't need every healthcare official
to be
burning bridges with their colleagues in
china
just
for proof of this there was
what is the guy's name he was the cdc
director underneath trump
robert redfield robert redfield when he
left he said now that i'm a civilian
it's okay for me to have an opinion
about this here is dr robert redfield
when he sat down with sanjay gupta i am
of the point of view that i still think
the most likely
ideology of this pathogen and wuhan was
a from a laboratory
you know escaped that's my own view it's
an only opinion i'm allowed to have
opinions now other people don't believe
that that's fine science will eventually
figure it out it's not unusual for
respiratory pathogens that are being
worked on in a laboratory to infect the
laboratory worker
what i thought was interesting in that
statement is he said now that i'm a
civilian i can have an opinion about
this so
what he was telling us is that when he
was a healthcare official he was bending
over backwards not to be offensive
because that would have screwed up his
job he wouldn't have been able to do his
job if he had offended people
so a lot of people are attacking francis
collins and anthony fauci over them not
being tough on china but it's i would
argue that it's not their job to be
tough on china
i think i i also want to emphasize a
point that we discussed in our first
interview is that sometimes you have to
look at individuals in totality looking
at all of the things they do not not
just on one issue so
they could be doing a pretty bad job on
one issue but you need to consider that
they are doing like 99 other things and
if you look at the 100 things they're
doing they're actually doing a lot of
good and and you need to calibrate your
judgment of of these individuals like i
always try to give them maximum like
benefit of the dots like is it that they
just haven't spent enough time looking
into this issue so they themselves are
not all aware of what's happening and
they're just trusting the words of
people who might have conflicts of
interest
so like if they were very good friends
with peter daschak maybe they just kept
getting the wrong information over the
past two years i mean people dashing has
on so many accounts
contradicted facts then that laser were
found to be true so like i i think it
depends like how much info uh francis
collins for example and then dr anthony
farci actually getting and who who are
your sources so
i i have no interest in saying someone's
evil or not i just want to say what is
the information that you have
for example if you have a lot of
discussions that were rejected maybe it
helps the public trust if you unredact
those email conversations so we can see
what you were actually saying about the
origin of clove 19 in early 2020 one of
the things that i think we're seeing
here too
is a difference in how
well
we're kind of seeing an old school
version of public health communication
that no longer works
in the internet era it used to be that
you would figure out what you think is
best and then act as if you have
absolute confidence in that and go talk
to the public in that way
and that would be reassuring to people
people want a strong leader you know
nowadays
that doesn't work because we have so
much
communication and access to information
that
you can tell when someone's
pretending to be confident about
something and that's
i think that's a big thing that changed
and i don't think that
we've really adjusted and how we speak
publicly yet and i don't even know how
we adjust because
everything's complicated and new this is
one of the things that i i see so many
people getting really angry at them and
saying oh they failed this and that but
we're dealing with all of this for the
first time and they're dealing with the
power of the internet really in full
force for the first time
and how that changes
how
communication should be done i mean
pretty much everything they learned
about pr
is wrong now especially for situations
where the science is still emerging
where the science is still being
performed still being conducted
so
how can you be confident when you don't
know so i almost feel that
at least for me as a scientist if i
don't know even if it's a very basic
fact i'll just say right now i can't
remember i'll tell you later when i
google it
rather than forcing something that
trying to force myself to have a best
guess and getting it wrong i think the
future will be a lot more transparent
because of this i think everyone's
taking note of this
one of the things that that's
would have been nice too is if we had
more people that were the
representatives or if we cycled through
people i think
it's so hard to be right all the time
and it's and what happens is you can be
right 99 of the time and be doing good
99 of the time but those
that one percent where you keep screwing
up every once in a while that builds up
people remember that they don't remember
all the times you were right
and so
it's so easy to build
massive enemies the other thing right
now in the united states we have the the
politicians the the president is liberal
a lot of the political power is liberal
right now
and the public health officials
were liberal back when it when we had
trump there was that mix between the two
and so you you could have communication
to both sides of the aisle that worked
pretty well i mean francis collins
actually was the only
person that i i see in like public
health right now that's actually good at
talking to the right and now he's gone
right now there's kind of a vacuum
there's not good information that people
on the far right
or just you know even the middle right
really trust because they're skeptical
of people on the left
and that's a problem that i
i'm kind of amazed that we didn't try to
address that early on i'm kind of amazed
we didn't get some we didn't try and
keep someone like robert redfield
who is who you know he was a
conservative christian guy but have you
seen all the angry tweets about him from
vibrologists they don't seem to like him
very much okay
especially after he made that comments
about the lab league that's okay i mean
what i'm saying is that people on the
right who don't trust the scientific
community and don't trust the liberal
politicians they would have had robert
redfield to be on their side right they
you know he looks you know he's got kind
of like an amish style beard and he's
got
he's i'm pretty sure he's a christian
people need to feel like they're being
represented
and i think right now one of the reasons
that
public health has been so poor
in reaching the right is that
people on the right don't feel like
anyone in the government right now
represents them so
and we can complain and say like well
they just need to grow up but that's
that's not how the world works you have
to meet people where they're at so and i
think the media bezel of responsibility
for this too and we even saw this
playing out with the vaccines right so
which president would take credit for
the vaccines and i think that is such a
bad way to to promote vaccines to say
that this is a trump product or this is
a biden product like why not let's just
say these are vaccines and no none of
the presidents are responsible for the
vaccines they happen because people
working on vaccines made the vaccines so
that
it shouldn't be a situation where uh i'm
only gonna get vaccinated if this was a
trump vaccine i'm only gonna get
vaccinated if this was a biden vaccine
that that is insane yeah yeah
but again that's where that's where
we're at it's like we can't
yeah
we've got to get there we got to get
there from here so i don't know if did
you see that trump came on and said that
he he got his booster shot and he was
booed off the he wasn't booed off the
stage but he was booed by his audience
did you see that no i did not see that
but i can't imagine it there's been a
call from public health officials
they've been asking him to talk about
the importance of vaccines and he
finally did it and he did it to the uh
like
to the hatred of his own audience it was
it was interesting
both the president and i are facts and
uh did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so um
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months that was supposed to take from
five to 12 years because of that vaccine
because of that vaccine
millions and millions of people i think
this would have been the spanish flu of
1917 where up to 100 million people died
this was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
whatever happens politically
it's very secondary to me the main goal
is to get more people to be vaccinated
right so
the point is not to have a whole faction
of the country saying that i'm not going
to be vaccinated because this is a
democratic product
right
and unfortunately that's what we've seen
with the origin of kovid it's it's
gotten to this very bizarre situation
where if it comes from a market somehow
the democrats win or if it comes from a
lab the republicans win yeah but the
truth of the matter is like
if we don't find the origins like we all
lose together not even as just americans
alone but everyone around the world
loses together
yeah yeah because we can't turn off this
faucet as you were saying i do want to
talk about omicron really quickly and
vaccines because i think you would
probably know
understand this a lot better than i
would a lot of people are
upset with
the because the vaccines aren't working
so well against omicron
and so they're
they're saying well then what was the
point of any of this
what is your response to that
i think that that there's responsibility
on both sides and unfortunately
some people had marketed the vaccines as
a way to uh have sterilizing immunity so
by that what i mean once you get
vaccinated you'll never get covered 19
again in your life that kind of
sterilizing immunity but in reality
because this virus went on to infect
like 300 million people
inevitably more and more variants
evolved and some of these evolved in
immuno-compromised people for example or
just through passing through areas where
there was already a lot of pre-existing
infection so some of these variants can
get around human immune responses to the
original version of saskov2 so what
we're seeing is that some of these new
variants can re-infect people who have
been infected before or it can even
infect people who have been fully
vaccinated with the vaccine that's
designed based on the original size kobe
2 virus so now there's a lot of talk in
the scientific community about how we
should update our vaccines because one
advantage of the uh mrna vaccine is that
you can quickly update them quickly uh
like it's like updating your your mac
system right so every every few months
you can update the new version so why
not design vaccines where people are
being inoculated with the spikes from
omicron delta alpha maybe all at once in
a cocktail that way you have a very
diverse immune response when i talked to
people about vaccines a lot of people
did have the impression and i'm not sure
where they got it but they they did
think that it was going to be one
vaccine and then then we're done well
the two doses of the vaccine and then
we're done but the research on
coronaviruses back from the 80s
the the other coronavirus we have four i
think four coronaviruses that that
circulate in humanity
that we've had for
ever we knew from research back in the
80s that we only maintain immunity to
those for about for between two and ten
years and maybe even less so we already
knew that this was going to be a a
problem indefinitely but i guess that
was not communicated to the public i've
been looking at the the data the
research on this
since the start
and the picture that i have of this has
been just dramatically different from
everybody that i talked to so somehow we
did a bad job communicating the science
of all this yeah i think part of the
problem was that people were
trying to make people get vaccinated so
and sometimes they might have gone
overbought with selling the benefits of
being vaccinated so instead of being a
bit more cautious with how you would try
to set expectations for this vaccine
they were like this is the best vaccine
ever it's the safest vaccine ever
you will never get covered again and i
think when you go too far
and when uh reality falls short of
expectations that's when a lot of people
turn around and say you lied to us right
so i always think that people have to be
more moderate when they sell a product
under promise over deliver right
that's that's a great phrase
yeah it's been very it's been very
unfortunate to see this the anti-vaccine
stuff just explode i've actually
hesitated to talk about lab leak origins
even though it's been a concern of mine
one thing that i've noticed is that
as soon as i turn people onto this idea
then they go online and start looking at
it and if you go online and start
looking at the lab leak origin you
immediately get thrown into this world
of conspiracy theories anti-vaxx really
deep and quite crazy conspiracy theories
and i've seen some very intelligent
people just fall down the rabbit hole
a colleague of mine has gone deep down
this
and is just
every once a while i go check on check
on his stuff and he it looks like he's
gone crazy it's absolutely bizarre his
audience went from you know people who
were very scientifically literate and
interested and curious to
now has now his whole audience is just
like raging conspiracy theorists and
he's being fed by that and he's just
getting deeper and deeper and deeper
into this
and it's crazy to see
that happen
and so i worry
am i throwing people into that garbage
heap am i directing them to that chaos
i think it's important to point uh
people are hearing about the lab origin
hypothesis to to properly wetted sources
to at least peer reviewed letters or
things and then or um my book
i was just gonna say that but you beat
me to the punch well of course i'm
speaking of self-bias because but i was
extremely careful with this book so it's
like 15 of the book is citations i i
wrote this with a very scientific
approach and any fact in that can be
fact checked by you by the reader
themselves um we don't use dubious
sources we use things that i would trust
like i can verify with my own eyes and i
did
i think one thing that surprises a lot
of people is that i'm actually very
skeptical whenever i uh first hear of
lamp origin related evidence and this
has led to a lot of disagreements and
fights between me and and
internet slews and even scientists and
journalists who are very pro-lab league
so i actually get into like very nasty
disagreements with them i'd say those
disagreements are fiercer than the
disagreements i get into with the
natural origin crowd if you can imagine
that because uh
the folks who who
from the lab league psych site who see
me downplaying or dismissing what they
think is very strong evidence for a lab
leak they they can accuse me of being
uncovered like covering for uh fauci you
know that kind of thing like they
immediately jump to the idea that i have
some sort of agenda to protect
scientists when actually i'm just
exercising the same skepticism towards
lab related evidence as i am towards
natural origin related evidence so i
think if you if you find yourself
consistently getting into disagreements
with people who are like quote on your
side then i think you will
at least be a bit safer knowing that
you're not pandering to them and that
you're not getting siloed yeah
have you decided
when you'll just step away even if it's
never figured out do you have plans to
step away from even talking about it or
you do are you going to keep on doing
this until we find an answer
well i think that there are ways to take
steps back without stopping entirely and
actually the book was my way of closing
the book on this issue so i wanted to
get everything i know down into one book
and and give it to people as a resource
so like here if you need to know what i
know then this book is your resource
i might still play a role peripherally
in in some of these commissions and
investigations that start next year
uh into the original code 19 but i
actually have a plan to slowly just
leave social media and i i've already
started just this this week is it's just
um
once you stop engaging with people you
don't feel that pool to get back into
twitter and into disagreements or
exchanges with people on twitter so i
think i think i've done what i set out
to do i'm very satisfied with where i am
right now and i don't
um
i love my job i love what i do at work
so i want to go back to that like 100
like 200 percent so
the twitter thing is not sustainable and
it never was meant to be sustainable i
just wanted to stay on here long enough
until the book was out and true
investigation is in sight and i think
those two things are happening
big question
for anyone who's supporting what some
say is a conspiracy theory
what would convince you that
a natural origin is the actual true
cause of this
i'd like to lay out um
what will convince me which is a robust
investigation into the origin of coven
19. so what i mean by a robust
investigation is it's like there are
three things that need to be
investigated the first thing is tracking
all of the early cases so china has told
us that they
failed to identify any case before
december 2019 which i find very
surprising because they have the best
expertise in the entire world for
tracking novel coronavirus outbreaks in
that city in uhan and yet it's telling
us that in the city where almost
everything is monitored
everyone has an id you've got your top
sales experts there you could not even
trace back
from from hundreds of cases in december
to any cases in november that's very
shocking to me um
because without this data without
knowing who the first cases were
how do you know what their exposures
were how do you find the source of this
virus so that that investigation is very
important to me it has to happen in
order for like specific this positive
evidence to be found surrounding the
origin of kova 19.
so the second prong is an investigation
into natural origins so there has been
some investigation according to the
chinese authorities and also by
scientists outside of china who are
sampling bats and wildlife trade animals
and
collectively they have not found any
traces of sars2 like viruses
in any of the wildlife trade save for
three pangolin coronaviruses they're
still quite distantly related so they're
definitely not
the precursors or siblings of south
korea too um the issue is that china has
told us that they shut down the
um farms from south china that was
supplying wuhan city without testing so
this is kind of shocking is that one of
the first things you should do is test
the suppliers to see whether the virus
was there like yes shut them down but
don't you want to definitively know that
this was the source so that you can
eliminate this national security concern
so we need access to samples we need
access to the farmers the traders we
need to talk to them we need to to
figure out
is there is there actually any direct
evidence pointing to a natural origin of
south kov2
and the last the last prong is an
investigation of a lab origin so what
this means is getting the lab notebooks
rackets uh having protected interviews
of any key witnesses personnel
collaborators in and outside of china
because
even if this virus the genome is 100
natural it doesn't rule out some very
plausible lamp origins which is for
example a researcher goes and samples a
sick animal or human and brings the
virus back into the town
so without seeing their medical records
without knowing who the earliest cases
were without knowing what viruses when
their collection or what experiments
were being done it's very difficult for
us to rule out a lab origin yeah i told
people to comment because you know last
last time you were on obviously this was
this was a controversial topic so i said
send any questions the comments you have
and we will address those a couple
people did that directly they either
emailed me or they commented clearly one
person was saying why would china want
to let foreign
powers investigate their laboratory the
u.s obviously would never let any any
foreign country do that to our
laboratories so why should we expect the
same from them
and i do
have sympathy for that argument a lot of
the weird behavior that we've seen from
the chinese government and from the lab
and so on could easily be explained by
not wanting
to get sabotaged by investigators china
has a lot of enemies well i don't think
china has many enemies that want to see
it completely fall but there's a lot of
people that want to see china stumble
and this is a great opportunity to throw
something in them in the mix and help
them stumble so a lot of their
even taking down their database which
seems really weird
that does make sense if you're worried
that someone's trying to insert
something into your database that wasn't
actually there how do we investigate
that lab in a way that's not going to
reveal projects they might be working on
that they want to keep secret for patent
reasons for financial reasons things
that might be misinterpreted i have
these uh skulls behind me here
and they're plastic they're they're bone
clones replicas and i take them with me
when i travel and do do speaking events
and one time i had my bag searched at
the airport
there was a lot of misunderstandings
yeah
you can be totally innocent and cause
some major drama in this case it was it
was it wasn't a big deal i just told
lady i was like there's a skull in there
that's plastic i promise you it's
plastic it looks very real
and and she she freaked out she's like
you show show me how i know that's not
real and like it's like here let me can
i pick it up she's like yes i'm not
touching that so i picked it up and i
showed her you know you you can look
inside of it and see that it's plastic
uh which is good advertising for bone
clones by the way
who makes that replica but it would be
very easy for people to misinterpret
things that they find in that lab and
blow things out of proportion i mean
there are reasons aside from being
guilty that china is going to be acting
weird about their lab right yeah i'm not
saying that china is a beacon of
transparency for the rest of the world
to follow
but
let's look at the first sales outbreak
like the scientists from then were very
excited to share any evidence they had
of the origin of that outbreak so yes
there was a cover-up about how large the
outbreak was to save face they didn't
want to show that you know they had
thousands of cases or anything like that
they wanted to to make it sound like
everything was under control but the
scientists were investigating the origin
of that were actually very forthcoming
with with new data like hot off the pcr
machine like hot off the like you know
culture so by may 2003 so only two
months since the virus was isolated from
a patient they had already shared data
and news about an animal source
with like they they had tested animals
in the market and found signs of the
virus infecting those animals so very
excited to share all the data they had
because they wanted to demonstrate
mastery
over like tracking and outbreak and they
did like even to this day the chinese
scientists who solved the origin of sas
one they're very well known like they're
they're reputable for being the ones who
attracted independently without any
external help but today we're seeing the
complete opposite is that they're saying
we can't even find any cases before
december
when the outbreak was detected we didn't
even test for any of the antibodies of
of banked blood samples we didn't even
bother to see how early this albright
might have started in ground zero in in
wuhan city so not to say they needed to
test like millions of samples across
china but do not even do it at uhan to
not even bother to check i mean
how could it be that they have the best
experts for tracking styles outbreaks in
this city and they're telling us that
they have zero ability to investigate i
mean i think that yes there's a cover-up
they tried to cover up and they tried to
show they did a really good job of
containing the outbreak they tried to
tell people it's not spreading amongst
humans yet
but there's also this part where they
kind of look very incompetent at this
rate that they can't even trace any
early cases they didn't even check the
animals being supplied to uh didn't even
check for antibodies it's just a
to me it doesn't sound reasonable and
the database they easily could have sent
a copy to multiple collaborators on date
zero and then they would have seen yeah
that if there's a future insertion
they'll say no we got the original copy
and and this is from someone else like a
bad actor yeah yeah
it is it is difficult to explain
everything that was happening there
but i mean we might someday find that
there is an explanation for all that it
might have been this guy right here was
scared to lose his job so he made this
happen and that happened it could have
just been a series of people being
scared of getting in trouble i mean for
me
there was a huge change in approach so
we knew that you know in the early week
of this outbreak it seemed like they
truly were convinced that it came from
the market not just the local cdc even
the beijing cdc flew in to sample that
market they weren't just sterilizing the
market they took hundreds of environment
samples and hundreds of animal samples
they went on to test hundreds and
thousands of animals in the province in
the city like they were clearly looking
for the animal sauce they were really
keen on this and then suddenly in early
2020 like all of that stopped like they
just like i'm not testing any animal
samples from the farms i'm not even
looking for early cases anymore
everybody destroy your patient samples
um no more speaking to the press like
there was a gang order on the national
cdc all the networks all the cdc
officers were gagged in february
scholars in china were gagged they were
told not to submit anything on the
origin unless it had been through
multiple levels even government level
approval so somewhere there was a change
in mindset and i find that very
disturbing i mean that could be
explained by they figured out what
actually happened and they weren't happy
with what happened and they didn't
weren't they didn't want the world to
find out it could also have been that
like
uh this is now a world problem now and
people are gonna be trying trying to
blame us so no more talking about this
everything's very speculative
a huge chunk of the evidence that people
are talking about online for evidence
that this was a lab leak is
evidence of look they're acting guilty
they're for they probably
it's probably a lab leak i understand
that that should be taken into
consideration but i also don't really
know
i just don't understand how china would
behave otherwise i mean i don't i'm not
smart enough to understand i know that
with sars one even at the beginning they
were trying to cover it up and the world
health organization is like hey we know
that you guys have an outbreak will you
just tell us now
that was back when the world health
organization had more teeth they had
back channels they were actually
investigating all the nations that were
part of the the who they had little back
channels to make sure that they weren't
hiding stuff we no longer have that but
i want to point out again that they were
covering up the scale of the outbreak
but they weren't covering up the
competence of their scientists so their
scientific teams were very eager to show
the world that we can track this yeah so
cases had first started appearing and
being detected in clinics in the main
cities in january 2003
once they knew that all the doctors were
on alert and they even traced back cases
as far back as november 2002
uh but by much they knew it was a
coronavirus and by may all the
scientists were sharing data about
antibodies tested of animal traders
animals if uninfected so even though the
scale of the outbreak was being hidden
and the new patients were being hidden
in elevators being driven around the
city in ambulances where the who was uh
visiting but the scientists themselves
were very interested to show the world
we're awesome at this we know how to
track the virus but here in this case
china is trying to show the world a
really good job containing the outbreak
they even have a whole museum an exhibit
set up in uhan precisely about this but
they are making their scientists look
extremely incompetent like so
incompetent that they don't test for
antibodies they don't test
they don't look for early cases uh that
they don't even test the animals being
sent to the city like it's just
it's just a picture of of very
well i'd say it's a pattern of
magnificent disinterest in this national
security concern so it's like this this
killer virus has emerged we're doing
nothing none of the basic things to
detract its origin so you would be
convinced if we had this three-prong
investigation so track early cases get
all that data public
uh look for something in the wild
what if what if the wild
search research only found something
like what would that convince you alone
without investigating the early cases
and without investigating the lab yeah
it would depend on the type of evidence
like what is it because it's been two
years since this outbreak started so if
if in the first month or first few
months of the outbreak they had found
the animal host then then sure
everything's great but two years later
how did they find an animal host because
by now like all the evidence is gone and
that's why this comes back to the first
part of our discussion is that there's a
time limit for investigating the origins
it's not something where we can say
let's let's take the first five years of
a pandemic to stop cases and then after
that and go back and look for clues
about the origin it's too late what you
talked about last week we actually do
have data from emails and conversations
outside of china
there are other ways to look into this
as well
my bias is leaning towards
i really hope this is wild
that this doesn't start a big conflict
between
china and the united states and it
doesn't cause a big conflict between u.s
researchers and chinese researchers yeah
i mean i i have that bias too i know
this sounds surprising but i i have that
bias too i don't want scientists to get
in trouble but my way of thinking is
that if scientists are not the ones
taking the initiative to investigate a
lab origin then who will right so i'd
rather that scientists are part of the
investigation then we just sit this one
out because absolutely
i care that we find the truth but i i
think i think i will be easier to
convince than you because uh
because you want it to be true yeah yeah
yeah so i mean i i'll say this as i've
been in science for many years and
that's one of the worst things that can
happen to a scientist is that you want
something to be true so much and i've
seen this happen to even top scientists
that they are willing to overlook
negative data they're willing to
cherry-pick data and that that is very
extremely dangerous so
not just for science but all the people
implicated affected by this and in the
same group the people who try to
reproduce that work and find that
there's a whole bunch of negative data
missing so
deep down in my core as a scientist i
absolutely reject that people
people cherry-picking data or being
lenient with themselves i always find
that we have we have to be the most
critical of our own favorite hypothesis
because if you don't you will you will
roll you will ever launch into into
misconduct
into scientific disinformation yeah one
of there was a there was a saying that i
think i emailed this to you um
it was
it's about confirmation bias yeah i
don't remember who said this but someone
said
the best antidote to confirmation bias
is to argue with people who have
different confirmation bias yeah yeah
who have conflicting confirmation bias
and uh i i feel
that's what we do in science i mean it's
how how this project works i think that
the public in general
has a bias towards a lab leak
it's really hard for us not to want to
blame someone for a catastrophe i mean
this is i think this is one of the
reasons why people believing in god and
the devil is because when something good
happens they want to be grateful to
someone and when something bad happens
they want to blame someone well i think
one way to counter that sensationalism
around this topic is to let scientists
on this topic from each side talk to
each other more often in public directly
live events so this way you remove any
curtain of conspiracy and any sense of
censorship or anything if you let them
talk directly to each other and i'm not
saying that
uh this needs to happen for like
scientific issues that are already set
in stone but even even then it might
help if you see people talk about
vaccines in the in the context of autism
and things like that if we can have more
of these public events where people are
talking directly to each other that
removes this these silos on facebook or
other social media where people are just
listening to their own collective bunch
of experts so i was really happy in
september of this year when i was
invited to be part of a four person
panel by the aaas the science magazine
yeah that was great yeah yeah i love
that uh they put me and jesse bloom on
on the more agnostic slash lab that big
site
uh versus lynn farwang from singapore
and michael varubi from arizona who are
much more on the natural origin side so
we we
directly debated each other directly
discuss what is it that we know and
don't know what needs to be investigated
and i thought that meeting was extremely
constructive and very civil yeah me too
yeah unfortunately on twitter it's it's
a complete like [ __ ] show but when
you're directly speaking to someone
you're much more civil you can be tough
on them
but you're less likely to start
hurling insults at each other twitter
does that twitter early on in my twitter
adventures i got into a twitter fight
with a guy perry marshall
and then and then i invited him to come
on my show and we had a just fine
conversation i feel like a lot of nuance
and and
important information and questions are
lost when experts don't directly talk to
each other so actually i'm very
interested in being invited to to more
interviews where for example i can talk
to the authors of the proximal origin
letter the nature medicine who set the
tone for this discussion in early 2020
or to discussions uh interviews where
the world health organization new
investigative team the sago team any of
their members are brought in to to just
bounce ideas and see like what what is
it that makes them think the natural
origin is more likely and how would they
investigate it and and or how should
they investigate that more origin so i'm
very interested in these more
constructive uh interviews you were on
there with michael warabee am i saying
his name right
i think so
and he wrote a letter with you
in support of
well this this was in the early days
when the the lab league hypothesis was
demonized
by pretty much everyone in the
scientific community and
well especially
i shouldn't say in the scientific
community because i had i was talking to
lots of people and they're like no the
lab lab leak is definitely possible but
not probably since the start
yeah they weren't probably saying that
and in the news it was no this is uh
this is definitely a conspiracy theory
but
he wrote a letter with you and you also
had uh
ralph barrack yes ralph barrick was on
there and he's the one who runs the lab
in north carolina right yes and he
collaborated with dr sri jungli from the
uhan institute of virology and peter
dashang from the equal health alliance
that was pretty nuts that he got on
there and he he wrote this letter saying
no we need to investigate a lab leak
hypothesis yes he had actually been
saying that since even early 2020 but it
was an italian documentary where he was
quoted and so not many people watched
that documentary he said whether or not
this virus was genetically engineered
it's only in the records of this lab and
wuhan
yeah that letter
i'm going to be showing it on screen
here for everyone to see
it's very important i think that people
read that there's some really good
messaging in there you guys worded that
beautifully michael michael warby now
regrets
he doesn't i don't know if he regrets
having signed that but he regrets the
the backlash that it had we went from
the lab league being demonized in the
media to right after that was published
that the lab leak was then considered
the most likely probability and actually
this happened again with your testimony
last week
i saw it was one of the british journals
is saying loudly because now the most
likely hypothesis oh was it the daily
mail
yeah yeah i think it's the daily mail
yeah
yeah i mean i i really wish that the
news organizations would report the
context of that quote yeah so i had been
asked alongside uh my co-author matt
riley as well as the lancet's chief
editor richard horton to each give a
number
a probability estimate of each origin
hypothesis and you refused we all
collectively refused but but richard
haughton said that he he favored the
world health organization stance which
was a lab origin was extremely unlikely
but i often my judgment which was that i
actually lean towards a lab origin but
there's no evidence right now that
there's no specific evidence that can
confirm or rule out any of these
hypotheses so throughout the meeting i
kept enforcing that we need an
investigation i even pressed the lancet
and other
journals to release all the original
manuscripts that had been sent to them
uh from china yeah by scientists
describing the early days we need to
take a look at what's in there we know
that manuscripts were withdrawn yeah
like after gang orders went down so we
need to know what journals had in their
hands in the early days of the pandemic
yeah i think that's that's a really good
strategy i don't know if it would be
wise to
declassify all that right off the bat
but definitely people need to be looking
at that i mean that's a huge source of
fresh information especially for people
who are like intelligence agencies and
so on that
that can look at stuff before they want
to release it to the public because
i mean one of the really nasty things
about this whole situation is that
anytime information gets out into the
public you get immediate explosion of in
the media yeah then picking sides you
get these conspiracy theories that
explode i i just really struggle with
the ethics of confidential information i
mean if you keep things
classified for a while even just for
temporarily there's a bunch of eyes that
don't get to see it that could
help link something that's important
but if you do declassify stuff right
away then you have this other problem
where everyone goes crazy
so i don't know what to do with this
it's it's a it's pretty
it's a complicated puzzle well that's
why i think it's so important to have
these commissions and investigative
teams set up asap because they should be
the ones previewing these uh new
documents and things that may or may not
deserve to be put out publicly just in
case they cause harm to individuals so
once you have these commissions then
then it's not a matter of am i exposing
these individuals to attacks but more of
the information can actually be expertly
reviewed and assessed first
um and that's why these commissions
should have people from both sides of
the issue
or people as centrist as possible as
much balance as possible in this team so
that uh people who each side trust
can be there to review this evidence i
think that that's key like having people
fro that represent many different views
many different fields of research
intelligence agencies scientists yeah
even get people like tom cotton in there
let everybody in on this
but
maybe don't give it to the
whole world all at once yeah declassify
things slowly but i don't but but it is
a mess it's very complicated do we want
to treat everyone like babies
i
it's it's a hard question
i want to make sure that we get
specifically to some questions that were
well written by youtube user ration
almind that's his that's his uh youtube
handle he gave six questions i there was
three of them that i thought were most
important but i think you wanted to just
address all six of them right yeah if we
have time
so here is what rational mind wrote
his first comment alina talks about the
proximal origins article in nature
medicine saying quote
the assumptions they make don't rule out
a lab origin at all so just because they
wouldn't personally design a virus this
way doesn't mean that this couldn't have
leaked from a lab by accident couldn't
have been the natural virus collected
brought to a lab grown and leaked end
quote
at no point does the proximal origin
article discuss the scenario of a
natural virus brought to a lab and
leaked shortly thereafter so that's true
but feels like a bit of a straw man of
their article they never argue along the
lines of quote we wouldn't have designed
a virus this way so therefore it wasn't
designed end quote
they mostly argue that the properties of
the virus appear more indicative of a
natural process than a deliberate
engineering the closest they came to
alina's description was in the section
about mutations in the rbd that's the
spike proteins binding region
there they basically argued that the rbd
wasn't optimal for binding human ace 2
and conclude this is strong evidence
that sars cov2 is not the product of
purposeful manipulation end quote
it seems quite clear to me from context
that when they say purposeful
manipulation they're referring to
manipulation with a deliberate attempt
at engineering a bioweapon targeting
humans but i agree the language is
fairly vague in this regard i wonder if
the language made more sense at the time
when the most prominent lab scenario
being circulated was one of a bio weapon
rather than an accidental release of a
pathogen of unknown virulence
so that is the first of six
comments by rational mind and if i could
summarize his concern here he worries
you've strawman their paper by
summarizing their argument as
quote scientists would not have designed
a virus this way therefore it wasn't
designed
proximal origins their letter was worded
in such a way that a lot of readers
including experts including journalists
and science communicators took away an
overly simplified message when people
read this paper the language was so weak
that they left thinking that this virus
must be natural in origin the reason for
that is because there's some quotes in
this proximal origin letter that are
very i'd say assertive
so they say
since we observed all notable sars2
features including the optimized rbd and
polybasic cleavage site and related
coronal viruses in nature we do not
believe that any type of laboratory
based scenario is plausible with the
accompanying press from scripps where
the lead author is from the title was
the covet-19 coronavirus epidemic has a
natural origin scientists say
and the author was quoted as saying we
can firmly determine that sars kovitsu
originated through natural processes
and then later the lead auto was
interviewed and and the news article was
published in a very reputable site the
sea draft site so it's a center for
infectious diseases calling the lab
release of a natural virus a conspiracy
theory so this article said that even a
natural virus leaking from a lab is a
conspiracy theory
and the lead author of proximal origin
told the reporter the new coronavirus
clearly originated in nature no question
about it now so if you look at all of
this collectively what was happening in
early 2020 with this letter is that they
were telling people that they have no
doubt that this virus was natural
and interviews surrounding it all said
that scientists say that this virus is
natural so so imagine the message that
was going out so i think that it's a
problem that the language was so vague
as russian our mind also thinks that
the wrong
and inaccurate message was taken away by
the public and even by expert science
communicators he says that he thinks
that maybe they were attacking the
bio-weapon hypothesis rather than an
accidental accidental release of a
pathogen i'm kind of bothered by that
because from the very start there were
several very distinct hypotheses there
was a bio-weapon hypothesis which most
people thought was garbage from the
start we had the the intelligence
agencies actually came out really early
on and said that no we don't have any
evidence that this is a bio weapon and
you would need a lot of evidence to
prove that to buy a weapon because of
the implications of that um in my in my
animation i actually talked about the
bio weapon and i said extraordinary uh
claims require extraordinary evidence
and a bunch of people are mad at me for
saying that like it's not an
extraordinary claim yes it is it would
cause a war it's a very extraordinary
claim plus it's a claim that requires
intent so you need to to find the intent
you need to prove the intent where is an
accidental lab release or just just
ignoring the the intent just a lab
origin
has a much lower burden of proof because
you don't have to say what was the
scientist thinking at the time when the
when virus escaped we already had very
very distinct
hypotheses and actually if you watch my
animation the lab leak hypothesis that i
show in there i show like this little
vial and there's a post-it note that
says this it's a new virus that larry
found and then one of the bottles breaks
so the first
thing that i was putting out there was
that this was a natural captured virus
that escaped from a lab accident as a
possibility the the conversations
happening in the public were covering
all these different possibilities even
tom cotton the bio weapon issue i think
it got blown up
i think it was a straw man
yeah
i mean and some very prominent news
organizations were doing this too which
is very surprising because you'd expect
them to be a bit more rigorous in their
fact tracking to actually watch tom
cotton's interviews and hear what he's
saying but unfortunately i think
in america especially but actually
worldwide like people tend to not even
care what the person is saying anymore
they just take what they see someone
else reporting and recycle it into the
news which is not great and even as
scientists this is the one thing you
should never do which is just copy
citations from other papers like you
need to go back to the original source
read that paper first and then cite it
the first time that i read it the
proximal origins paper that actually
calmed me down when i reread it i'm like
oh yeah this is
pretty misleading
next rationale mind talks about the
diffuse grant
i'm gonna be showing his comments on
screen right now so we can just
summarize him
yeah well he's arguing that the proposal
the diffuse proposal said this cleavage
site insertion would be happening at unc
where ralph barrack is based yeah so the
proposal said that this engineering of
stars like viruses would happen in north
carolina not in ohan city but my
response to that is that
this grant involved an international
team of scientists but amongst all of
these scientists the only ones who had
access to the raw sequencing data the
actual sequencing data they could detect
these novel cleavage sites and also had
the technology to insert these cleavage
sites into sales like viruses and had
the idea to do this and the funding this
lab was very well funded was the wiv
this this is the only partner out of
this entire collaboration that had
access to the sequencing data so this is
what sets them apart from ralph barrick
who did not have access to the
sequencing data and these labs were also
extremely well funded like just rolling
in the millions every year
that even if they didn't get this dapper
grant like easily elsewhere the chinese
government is traveling them with money
so
i also hesitate to speculate too much
i'd say that what is clear that we need
to do now is to get equal health
alliance to release all emails documents
data and exchanges relating to this type
of work so who proposed the idea that's
the main thing right so if uhan
scientists propose the idea then i think
we we're pretty good here so we know
that they already had the idea of what
preliminary work had been done and where
uh had any sequence or data even been
shared had they seen these novel
cleavage sites that were proposed in the
in the grants uh what about after the
grant was rejected was this idea
recycled in another grant or were there
more conversations about this type of
work so all of these are knowable like
we can literally just go to equal health
alliance in new york right now and say
can you share your emails so it's not
something where we will never know so a
lot of people don't like your uh
unicorn analogy
for various reasons i think maybe
because it sticks so well in everyone's
head
so and the concept pretty
yeah yeah i i think people have been
attacking it because it is an analogy
and of course it's easy to attack an
analogy
an argument by analogy
and then also because it that it
captivated the media so well
and so he's saying he's saying that your
unicorn argument isn't quite the smoking
gun that you think it is i don't think
you've ever called it a smoking gun no
and you've been very clear saying that
all we have is circumstantial evidence
yeah
and it's a striking coincidence but
coincidences do happen but in this case
what what is clear is that we can
investigate and we should investigate
that revelation that they had
plans
to add a fury and cleavage site was
pretty dang shocking yeah for me too
i want to talk about the other side of
the show and this actually
sixth question
he
he asked what you think about these
other relatives of starscope 2 that have
been found outside of china
and in laos i think it was we found
partial sequences that look like the
fuhrer and cleavage site no
so they they didn't uh i think that is a
speculation so uh my my colleague and i
uh shanghei chan from from canada and i
we recently published a peer review
paper explaining what exactly is it
about these uh
supposed intermediate fearing cleavage
sites that some scientists are reporting
so they are reporting a
a very boutique alignment of of
sequences
that cannot be substantiated by by hard
data by structural data so that when you
align sequences there are many many ways
to align them it's like solving a puzzle
uh until you get more evidence and
actually you get more and more robust
data you cannot say that this is the
correct alignment so you have to wait
for more data to occur before you you
yell like bingo so you can you're gonna
have one x and then you strike and you
say you got bingo you need to fill out a
lot before you have a confidence
alignment your paper got published right
this one
yeah it's in molecular biology and
evolution
yeah it's a it's a very reputable
journal in its field in evolutionary
biology michael warby
showed a diagram with the alignments
during his debate with you this paper is
a response to that
so it's not a response to mike warabi
himself but that there are a lot of
different scientists who are proposing
different alignments and what we are
saying is that none of these alignments
are well substantiated by data so i
think what we presented was actually the
most moderate and scientific view
possible is saying we don't have enough
data yet to call it
so
i i think that that's how scientists
should operate like not every
publication should be people confidently
asserting that they know something some
some publications some of the most
important ones are those that say we
don't know enough yet
but i also want to expand on this lowest
thing which is that actually more emails
were leaked over foyer
from only in october this year or even
november i think
showing that the wiv the ohio city of
biology had started amassing thousands
of samples from seven southeast asian
countries including laos they were
letting uh people from the uhanes to
biology come to collect samples or
sending hundreds of these samples up
into ohan city so
we know that they had access to these
viruses that look very similar to south
korea too not just in china but from
seven southeast asian countries and this
started in 2016.
we have no insight to what they found we
have like zero insights into what they
found between 2016 and 2019 when the
pandemic started so there is a lot of
investigative work to be done
so we found all of these new viruses
that are even closer to sarsko v2 barely
closer but they are a little bit closer
than ratg13 which was the first there's
one virus yeah there's one virus that's
slightly closer than rtg 13 yeah but
what what you're saying is that that's
kind of a mute point because these are
these are viruses that
the wuhan institute of ideology probably
already knew about well they had access
to that population of viruses and and
none of these close relatives have even
an intermediate viewing cleavage site so
they don't even have any insertions in
this area instead what we're seeing is
that amongst all the closest relatives
to south korea
they're very conserved in this area
there's no insertion in this area so
that means to us that this fearing
cleavage site appeared in south korea
too very recently because all of its
closest family members don't even have
an intermediate don't even have
insertion in that area
i do want to
point out though
because you know i've i've got you on
here saying something
that that a lot of people are in
conflict with so it's i think it's my
job to push back a little bit on this
there has been
from the start the the fear and cleavage
site argument has
evolved a lot to keep the conclusion so
i i am seeing people that are that are
trying to chase data to keep their
conclusion that this was genetically
engineered i am seeing that that
behavior at first everyone was saying
beta chronoviruses
never have fearing cleavage sites and
they're like uh yeah we've been working
with them like the mouse beta
chronovirus has one and we've known this
since like
early 2000s for me i even expressed that
this the fearing cleavage site it wasn't
its rareness that stuck out to me
actually it was the fact that it wasn't
even mentioned in the uhana city
biology's first paper so that for me was
the weird thing and i also used the
unicorn analogy i said it was like them
describing this newly found unicorn
describing everything but not the horn
like describing the hair describing the
hooves describing the fur and the skin
and everything and they're like oh we're
done here
not not mentioning the horn so for me
that was the thing that was that set off
a light bulb for me but even so i didn't
i didn't say that i think it's
genetically engineered i just said it
could be on the table but it's not that
interesting to me right now then there
was a bunch of noise about the
the codons being unusual and it seems
like that's been debunked now too like
we have found those codons used in in
nature as well as in the laboratory yeah
i actually push back on that too and i
got a lot of trouble
from the landing crowd because they're
like why are you dismissing our evidence
i'm like because it's not it's not that
strong of an argument so now we're left
with the the main evidence is the
circumstantial evidence saying that look
we have the darpa proposal
and we have the fact that
when people reported on this they
ignored the fear and cleavage site when
that should have been like the highlight
of their paper
and and we know that they were aware of
these sites they had a whole pipeline
for detecting them and they had in
recent years been inserting these into
other coronal virus parts so yeah it
wasn't like they had never encountered a
fearing cleavage site before again i'd
there is good circumstantial evidence
for this
but i am seeing this weird game where
people say
okay okay i guess you're right that
wasn't really that great of evidence but
what about this
and they keep trying to come up with new
excuses
and for me that's always that's always a
sign of conspiracy thinking you're in
love with your conclusion and you don't
want to to change but i i do admit that
we do still need to consider this a
possibility because of that darpa uh
paper and because of as as what you
mentioned the
the ignoring of this
when they first started talking about
these viruses
yeah i mean i i can't speak for
everybody who has argued about the
fearing cleavage side i can only speak
for what i have personally said so it's
this situation where people want me to
answer for the crimes of others
i would say like i'm very empathetic to
both sides but i i can't take
responsibility for extreme things that
other people said that i actually
disagreed with strongly at the time
yeah yeah
let's see
question number i'm gonna go back up to
question number five
you say it yourself every piece of
evidence on this can be dismissed and it
actually can be dismissed fairly easily
he's talking about something that i said
last time
and then i've i followed that up with
but it's when you take it all in
together that it likely looks like a
sign
here
and then he says but i for i prefer my
houses to be made of bricks not cards
i i agree obviously that's that's why
we're we're pushing for an investigation
is because the the bricks the bricks are
hiding somewhere in china either in the
wild most likely in china maybe we'll
find that this that this uh evolved
outside of china that's fairly unlikely
but most of these bricks probably exist
in china and china's not letting us go
find those bricks
and so that's
the
okay let me rephrase that the chinese
government is not letting us go find
those bricks people if you just say
china i find people think that that's
they interpret that as being racist yeah
but the
we wanna we want solid answers to this
we don't want to have to be speculating
like this is this is getting pretty
absurd
i fully support having a real
investigation that is how you will find
the bricks and some of them are outside
of china again these pieces of
information emails messages sent out so
but it's knowable it's within reach and
i disagree with people who who think
that we will never know
without even making any efforts to try
then he goes on to say that he thinks
it's obvious that you
think that this is the lab leak
something that i've heard from other
people is that you want this to be a lab
leak
i don't have any wants about this origin
what i want is an inve like an
investigation so i want an investigation
again as i pointed out earlier
in my experience in science the danger
is when you find yourself wanting a
certain outcome and that's that's when
i'm the most critical of myself
so
all the way through writing this book i
i was beating myself up all the time
like thinking i fact checked everything
to an inch of its life like to make sure
that everything here was as
unspeculative as possible as unbiased as
possible like i know it's difficult to
catch your own biases but i'm saying i
made best efforts um because
ultimately i have very long term
thinking about this book is that i want
it to stand the test of time i'm not one
of these people who just wants to let my
reputation wash all the flaw like
in the future when it's found to be you
know wrong or inaccurate or not
fact-checked like as a scientist my
reputation is built on being extremely
facts focused like very unbiased so this
book i wrote it
fully intending for it to stand any
assault
of time like no matter what you find in
the future like this book is like solid
it's made of like rock so
um
i'm not saying i don't have bias i
certainly have them everyone everyone
has biases but i did my best to be aware
of them
we've only got a few minutes left oh
yeah let's talk about your co-author
because a lot of people have been very
upset about his
his involvement in your book he's had a
long history of run-ins
like basically trying to say that
scientists are wrong in their consensus
about different things
he attacked the natural origin of hiv
and then he
has
said things about climate change or
where he's contradicting the scientific
consensus and so it's pretty clear
or it or it seems clear to a lot of
people that he has this kind of bone to
pick with scientific consensus in
general
and
maybe when he saw this it would he
pounced on because he's like aha
scientists screwed up here let me let me
rub it in their noses so first i'll
clarify that originally matt thought
that this was a natural origin so the
first time when we connected he was
writing an article about this coming
from nature so
um this was in early 2020 and it was
only overtime as more and more
disturbing information was released you
know about the miners about all these
closely related viruses under study at
wuhan that we both started thinking we
need to
lay out all the evidence and wherever
that points is where it points and we
eventually leaned towards a lab origin
because of the diffuse proposal that was
like a very
large switch for us um but by focusing
on matt
i i think that you have to look at him
in totality the same way you look at
like francis collins or anthony fauci in
totality
yes there are things that people will do
wrong in their lives or you disagree
with them strongly about especially the
older they are the more things you will
find that you disagree with them doing
like 20 30 years ago like we will all
eventually be cancelled so like don't
worry
um i will eventually be found guilty of
something as i reached my 50s and 70s so
when when i when he reached out to me
saying do you want to write this book
together i did go and carefully review
what else he had written but i didn't
find a deal breaker
yeah and i need to explain my story
before this makes sense is that i was
born in canada but i spent my childhood
in singapore and then i grew up i did
most of my young adulting in canada and
these two countries are extremely
multicultural in a way that's actually
quite different from the us even though
there are many different races and
cultures here is that in singapore and
canada people's different cultures are
celebrated like we don't try to hide
these differences or cancel each other
like we can still say merry christmas to
each other
we celebrate every holiday as the
intended holiday it was meant to be like
we we have this culture of tolerance i'm
not saying that these two countries like
perfect nothing wrong ever happens that
there is there's two disparities there's
two racism but it's very different from
the us where if if you disagree with
someone on one topic suddenly they're
they're the most evil and horrendously
ignorant person you've ever met like
that that couldn't fly in the country in
singapore in defense of my country
it seems a lot more like that on tv than
it is in real life okay
yeah yeah we we all get along with each
other for the most part
off off-camera yeah off reality tv i
said i i do live in canada now though so
yeah
what am i fleeing from
yeah so
i grew up in a place where you you had
no choice but to work well and live
while i play well with people who have
very extremely different values and
upbringing from you is and if you look
at matt ridley and i like
it's we are such different people with
such different experiences values like
i'm very extremely
liberal i'm not sure if you can tell um
and i i didn't grow up in a rich family
or anything um
you know i i tried to
i had a very extremely normal childhood
like not thinking i would do anything
great in my life so i think very
different from men who who
who was kind of like born into a great
tradition of like ridley's so
i think
the book is robust because two people
with such different backgrounds and
values and dispositions even can come
together and agree on every single line
that comes into this book so this is how
you check each other's biases as well um
i know it's not as robust if i wrote
this book with the lead author of
proximal origin maybe that would be more
extremely robust but i don't i don't see
how that collaboration can happen i did
i did actually reach out at one point
and said they want to co-write something
and i didn't get a response so
you can see i didn't even try but um
i think that people
are attacking the book and they see that
there's nothing to attack in terms of
its content so they're attacking my
co-author
and like i
you know it yes he has a conservative
network there's nothing denying that
like he he has a lot of friends who are
conservatives he gets invited on the
conservative shows because they know him
um and i'd say maybe it's my fault as as
the liberal person in this equation that
i have no networks to
liberal news media and they've some of
them have expressed fear of covering
this topic because of the the prevailing
perception of what the scientific
consensus is and and the idea that if
this comes from a lab then the democrats
have lost like that that's nuts so
there's a lot of that at play people
don't see the interviews that i am
declining
so i've already had many chances to go
and make this book a bestseller on some
of the most extremely watched cable news
or shows in this country in the in the
us and i've declined them all
because the profits of the book
don't mean anything to me if the book
gets denigrated
by by people being used for political
reasons being called like a right-wing
book like this is not what i want for
the book the book is meant to be a very
objective description of the search for
the original covet 19.
um and i also want to say one thing in
matt ridley's defense though even though
he has had some points where he clearly
clashed with a scientific establishment
he actually wrote some very prominent
books in science like his book genome
like it's the reason why one of my
friends is a scientist today so a lot of
people in my circle for liberals know
about these books they read these books
and
they have an impact on their life like
change their lives make them go into
science so i think we have to look at
things objectively not just going for
the parts we hate most about people
because
how how can you have a functioning
society
how can you be a world leader if people
inside are tearing each other apart for
the smallest things like that just
always going for the the one thing that
they hate about the other person instead
of all these other ways they could be
working together constructively one of
the things that i heard him say it's
actually in the in the the testimony
that you guys gave to par it was the
parliament right yeah the science and
tech committee he mentioned that there
was a bunch of stuff he kept wanting to
put in the book and you're like no you
can't put that in there that's not you
can't back that up scientifically and so
he was yeah i i run a really tight ship
and and you you'll hear that from other
people i work with too is that when i
send my comments or edits back to them
they're like the whole thing has been
rewritten
is that like i don't i don't let a lot
slide so you're the reviewer that no one
wants in their paper no no no actually
in in peer reviews i'm extremely like
not extremely nice and constructive and
detailed like i'm not mean i'm not mean
in my edits i'm just extremely thorough
yeah i a lot of training and editing
yeah
okay we only have a couple minutes left
before you got to go to another meeting
and i want to spend that time if you're
cool with this talking about racism
there has been an increase in racism
against asian americans
there are a lot of people who are very
concerned about
even talking about the lab leak
hypothesis they think that's going to
cause racism and i am not upset with
people being concerned about that and i
don't think it's
i almost don't think you can be overly
concerned about that because actually
racism
if it gets out of hand xenophobia once
it gets out of hand can be as
catastrophic as a pandemic and we we saw
this
with the holocaust that the holocaust
deaths are still higher than kovid's
deaths obviously the racism that we're
seeing right now is not nearly close to
being on par with the holocaust
but
you don't know where things could go if
so i i am very
in favor of us being cautious with
not
accidentally provoking racism i i take
seriously the allegations that we could
be doing what people call dog whistling
you know like we're we're giving things
to
racist groups and to hate groups that
they might be able to use however
the
dilapidly hypothesis i don't even see
how this could be a racist hypothesis
this is a failure of western science if
this was a lab leak this isn't a this
isn't a failure of chinese culture it's
a failure of western science and
actually the
the meat market hypothesis
there's a lot more that if you're racist
that you could blame china for yeah the
bad eating
which actually didn't happen like
actually didn't happen like there were
no bets so in these ohan markets the
liable hypothesis is not i don't see it
as being a racist hypothesis i do
understand though that just bringing up
these issues again could cause
conversations to happen again i was
talking to one of my old chinese
roommates and
he told me that
he felt nervous early on and there was
obviously some racial tension early on
but that's calmed down and i'm sure the
more as we start talking about this
stuff again
that there's a chance that that will
flare up again i think it's flaring up
more on the u.s side in terms of holding
u.s scientists accountable because we've
seen that a lot of these research
collaborations were led by u.s
scientists it was led by the equal
health alliance which is based here in
new york and heavily funded by u.s
sources but i think it's it's it's not
right to think of this in a country
specific manner because frankly this
type of research is happening in so many
countries
that it's not like it's a china thing or
u.s thing but now it's like everybody is
doing this type of research thing so
it's a criticism of the safeguards that
have been placed around this type of
research it's not a criticism of a
culture um and i think that the media
could help a lot by spreading that
message by also highlighting the brave
work of whistleblowers in china like
citizens journalists journalists
scientists doctors in china who gave up
a lot some even gave their lives the
report about this pandemic in the early
days and if you if you report those
stories more
then you will be countering that racism
because you will give people a much
deeper understanding of
it wasn't the culture that was at fault
and actually people in that culture were
so brave that despite being in a place
where they could be tortured in prison
disappeared for for sharing data with
the world they went ahead and did it
anyway so those stories need to be empty
and it's something that we've done in
our book and was also in that science
letter that i co-signed in may just just
reminding people that the first people
who responded were chinese like
whistleblowers and doctors like we we
owe so much to them and we shouldn't
forget their stories
yeah
well thank you for coming on this is
great i i hope that people feel like we
responded to their questions adequately
yes
come along material
yeah yeah we went up we went all over
the place this is fun uh i think i'm i'm
gonna take a break on this subject for a
while at least at least i think until
this this next weight the omicron wave
is done
because i actually do agree with francis
collins that probably right now
uh
we should be focused on
yeah
tamping down this uh this outbreak
i actually want to recommend to people
that i think would be great for your
interview for omicron which is probably
uh us-based uh trevor bedford he's very
solid on this
trevor bedford yeah and also
he's based in seattle uh and and and in
europe uh emma hotcroft cool great
well thank you i really appreciate your
time and uh merry christmas
oh yeah merry christmas
i hope you get more sleep sorry for
taking your sleep cycle
thank you